[Applause]
happy whatever day it is everyone
so talk about a spirited debate eight
people different ages backgrounds
talents and that was just in my bedroom
eventually the SWAT team was able to
Corral Kudlow
also we had the first Republican
presidential debate each of the
candidates tried to show why they would
do a better job as president than the
absentee in Chief
so how'd they all do the truth is the
entire debate was driven by one Indian
guy just like my Uber today
she would even laugh at something like
that says a lot about your tastes and
comedy
the vague certainly made his presence
known first of all his teeth are amazing
he makes Donny Osmond look like Johnny
Depp
but how weird was it that he was the
focal point and not to santis he became
the Catalyst for the most interesting
discussions he brought the fire the
ideas and that tremendous forehead
yeah you could show a double feature on
that thing
at the same time
not one after the other
because that's what normally a double
future is but you would be doing it on
two separate screens on his forehead
I'm glad I explained this for you
but it was Vivek who provoked the most
contentious debates
let me explain it to you if I can
I'll go slower this time now is not the
time for on-the-job training we don't
need to bring in a rookie the guy who
sounds like chat gbt standing up here
the last person in one of these debates
Brett who stood in the middle of the
stage and said what's a skinny guy with
an odd last name doing up here was
Barack Obama and I'm afraid we're
dealing with the same type of amateur
standing Sage tonight you have no
foreign policy experience and
wow talk about some hot Indian on Indian
action right there
[Applause]
if Joe Biden had just turned on the
debate he'd think 7-Eleven started a
talk show
for those of you who don't remember that
was Joe Biden's line after that Nikki
picked a fight with Tim Scott by hitting
him on spending a woman complaining
about spending that's got to be a first
a sexist would say
I'm looking at the people that laughed
at both the racist and sexist thing
truth is Nikki did have a good night
even if she played the woman card but
Vivek and Nikki both demonstrate the
changes that are going on in the
Republican party as the Dems become the
party of miserable single people with
graduate degrees in English the
Republicans have quietly become the
stewards of the American dream for
immigrants in the working class you know
the very thing the Dems pretended they
are meanwhile the Republican party has
become so inclusive they only kept one
black guy out
that's funny you jerks
I have no patience today but it's where
the energy in the party is it's where
the fresh ideas are it's where the
future lies which brings us to this
fella
now I know he sounds great but he looks
like a wax figure of himself
doesn't he feel like the past like
looking at a picture of your metal shop
teacher in your yearbook
he had the roughest hands
only eight fingers
but that added to his charm Rod DeSantis
had a good night but not memorable he
scored on crime Soros prosecutors but do
we need to see the clips not really it's
weird you know Florida's booming and
this guy this guy defied the lockdowns
and he fired two Soros prosecutors yet
when he puts on his tough guy voice he
sounds like a pissed off Barney Fife
it's not it's not fair really
of course there's Tim Scott great story
great guy but why did he leave halfway
through made no sense probably wanted to
get home for Gutfeld
the joke's on him it was preempted
Christy started off subdued he was so
quiet I could hear his stomach growling
but then he found his favorite little
spot and went after Trump
someone's got
to stop normalizing this conduct whether
or not you believe that the criminal
charges are right or wrong
the conduct is beneath the office of
presidents of the United States this is
the great thing about this country
booing is allowed but it doesn't change
the truth
and of course Trump wasn't there and
I've won a few fights like that as well
but without the opponent it feels like
Shadow Boxing there was this other guy
there too you know way at the end
was he one of the ushers
got a great look though not for
president of the United States but
definitely the governor of Transylvania
[Laughter]
ASA Hutchinson ASA Hutchinson wins in
the comb over category
this candidate had a cover-up even
before taking office
and of course Brett and Martha they did
exceptional they were like two
substitute teachers trying to control
the naughty kids at high school
detention
maybe next time give them Super Soakers
filled with cat pee
so as we gain some distance from the
debate I think what we'll remember is
vivec challenging The Establishment and
having fun doing it is he ready for the
presidency I don't know but why not I
mean Biden was ready
[Laughter]
look what he did
the less ready the better and true I
have underwear older than Vivek but I
stole them from Stuart Varney
I usually go commando
this was just the first of many debates
it was fun and very American and let's
not get too hysterical over it the truth
is nobody really laid a glove on Trump
he's got a bigger lead than Jimmy phela
and an ugly jacket contest the other
candidates are basically playing for
second place much like MSNBC or Jesse
Waters
but as the country gets to know these
other candidates Trump may have to show
up at some point otherwise he risks the
voters getting comfortable with some of
these new faces which makes me wonder
what did Biden think of the debate hey
hey I Tony don't bother me while I'm
doing my Pilates all right
I'll answer all your questions after I
do this blank
one
two three uh uh four
five
six
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
beg him to put them in handcuffs former
NYPD inspector Paul Morrow
she knows fake headlines like I know
weird can lines writer at The Babylon B
Ashley Sinclair
he dresses like a magician and can make
a comedy crowd disappear oh so Fox
Across America Jimmy phela
and she's like a muffler small loud and
often found underneath cars Fox News
contributor cat tip foreign
what did you make of the performance
you're used to bombing uh let's talk
about the bad first okay get it out of
the way burgum a mess okay how are you
gonna tell me you're gonna reign in the
government if you can't rain in your
eyebrows you know what I mean and ASA
Hutchinson you know what he convinced me
of at these debates they need that
Oscars Orchestra where you can play
people off if they talk for too long
because they all go past the Bell yeah
but if you kept playing maybe people
would get it and just shut up because
nobody cared what he said uh vivec was
obviously the Star because he's taken a
page out of Trump's notebook and that
he's running for class president you
know what I mean he's talking a lot of
smack he's getting in the way but the
joke you made about it you know you kind
of joke that it would be racist to say
he was a driver do you know my taxi
garage what a big deal he is right now
really because everyone in the garage is
Indian you know Indian or Muslim or
Middle Eastern you know I knew two guys
named Osama Bin Laden when I was a cab
driver like when they actually killed
them I got a phone call they're like
they got Bin Laden I was like for what
speeding you know what I mean it was
crazy so he is the same station right
now is what I think uh and honestly
anybody on that stage would kick Biden's
ass anybody all right well we'll see
about that Ashley welcome to the show
thank you for having me Vivek was
obviously the standout Chris Christie
tried hitting him but he should probably
stick to hitting the buffet instead
that's a little bit better for him
the reality is is that most Americans
many Americans are having a hard time
feeding themselves as well as Chris
Christie does and Vivek spoke to that
and he spoke to the Pains of everyday
Americans and that's why he he stood out
I would trust him as president there is
that that that thing that Chris Christie
says I hate the phrase normalizing I
really hate that and it's like okay
Trump has some faults but I mean you
know Chris come on you're normalizing
something else oh Gregory oh no I agree
with you Christy needs to step down and
then step up and then step down and step
up repeating this that was funny all
right Paul that was pretty good
you got to keep that in here you got to
use that this weekend can we edit that
out no don't applaud don't encourage it
don't encourage it all right uh nice
jacket thank you very much uh it was
tremendously entertaining that was the
most surprising thing I thought we were
going to get two hours of policy wonkery
and all that kind of stuff it was like
professional wrestling man it was I was
waiting for Tyrus I thought the
Highlight was when Nikki and vivec went
at each other wasn't it like she was a
hair away from saying young man go to
your room yeah right you kept you were
waiting for her just wait till your
father gets home
the low point for me Pence yeah all
right because he starts talking about
defund defund right last I checked you
were in office during the summer 11
2020. they were burning down Portland
and we're burning down Seattle they will
burn down Macy's here in Midtown I
didn't see any Rico's made against
antifa so sit down Grandpa yeah did he
did he have any power in that at all I
mean I'm the vice president you know I
mean I mean like I mean I don't know
what he I don't know what vice president
well it's the second guy under the
president that's the way they set it up
I wonder what president I would like to
be under
knock it off Obama
all right cat I know you watched it what
did you think it was fine yeah
I actually didn't find it to be that
entertaining but maybe I've just seen
too much
I think like Vivek was probably the
standout I completely agree it is really
interesting to watch all these people
though saying so many um awesome things
about Trump as if we don't also know
that they are also running against Trump
like when he came out and was like okay
he's the greatest president in the 21st
century I'm like okay well so you're not
but you're not gonna vote for him like
so I think that that's really
interesting because normally you'd see
them fighting against the front runner
but people aren't doing that it was a
lot of little interesting sub thoughts
there was the whole Tim Scott and Mike
Pence kind of trying to out Jesus each
other that was a little interesting but
I don't know I I mean I thought it was
they were all pulling so far below Trump
I think Trump's going to be the nominee
yeah I still I did the chat gbt line
do you believe the audience got that or
did they just laugh because it sounded
like an I.T phrase it was well delivered
it was almost like a punch line but
what's ironic is Christie thought it was
an insult everybody under 30 was the
best compliment in the world that's so
true it's funny that you say it's well
delivered because if anyone knows about
delivery it's Christy you know
all right
leave on a high note Jimmy leave on a
high note hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else